this is a tough gig and there's a lot of
ways to bottom out hey everybody so for
the no particular reason I kind of have
the inclination to talk about the topic
of reasons that youtubers have a
tendency to burn out and let me be very
emphatic about this no I have not burned
out I'm not stopping I'm not slowing
down my schedule everything is the same
it's just a topic I want to cover ok now
this is a combination of the things that
I've had to account for to keep my own
schedule up and adjustments that I've
had to make over the years watching
youtubers of varying sizes some
significantly larger than me many much
smaller than me burnouts tall or
otherwise kind of fade off and this is
probably it's not quite like a how-to or
whatever but it's things to watch out
for if especially if you yourself are
thinking about trying to get into this
gig which it's it's a tough gig like
seriously you have to love doing this
but we'll get to that sort of thing
anyways so I've got a few of these
written down and a lot of these do
overlap so there are some recurring
things first thing you dedicate yourself
to what is ultimately a niche topic
think of whatever is your favorite thing
to talk about your favorites fandom your
favorite craft your favorite whatever it
is the thing that you think you could
talk about until the end of time and
then try actually talking about it on a
regular schedule for week after week
month after month year after year it's a
little bit tougher than it sounds now
that's not to say it's impossible there
are nice channels out there that
actually zero in on one thing and keep
doing it
year over year over a year I think a
great
example would be snez drunk that channel
has been going for years and is still
talking about retro games focusing on
the Super Nintendo or Super Famicom and
I would have thought that he would have
burned out on topics by now
and he didn't now when I say niche I
mean pretty narrow because saying say
specifically Super Nintendo or Super
Famicom like he deviates a little but he
doesn't change this format that's pretty
neat Gaming is broad so like for me geek
culture and fandom that's broad doctor
who is niche now while I talk about
Doctor Who more than I talk about
anything else it is not the only thing I
talk about and it never will be because
while I can talk about Doctor Who a lot
I think if it had if I made the decision
was the only thing I was going to talk
about I would have run out of stuff to
say a while ago and I think that's
something a lot of people don't account
for they think oh but I've got this long
long list of topics I'm like you're
gonna burn through that a lot quicker
than you think you are and that's
assuming you don't start to lose
interest in talking about the same thing
over and over and over again and I have
seen channels decide that they were
tired of the topic that they built
themselves on and try to pivot and have
it go very badly I don't want to name
names but within the WHO Tube community
there have been channels or at least one
that I can think of that tried to move
off of talking about Doctor Who and it
um it didn't pan out very very well at
all but you have to be really careful
now that's not to say you can't talk
about in each things but be careful
about dedicating yourself to one
specific niche thing even if it's
something you're passionate about
next up your output schedule now it is
super important if you're going to try
and do this and you're going to try and
actually build a following cuz like if
this is a hobby this is like I'll make a
video when I have time I feel like it
cool awesome that's a valid way to do
this you can do this for fun not
everyone has to try and build a
following but if that's what you're
going to do a regular output schedule is
very very important
and I know a lot of us can look at some
of the really big youtubers out there
and certainly a lot of the ones I Meyer
I can look at the work of somebody like
contra points or folding ideas or
philosophy tube or even someone like
Sara Z and well you know they're putting
it some of them are putting out like a
video a month and they're doing great
like yeah but they caught a wave in most
cases they like they had something that
really caught on at some point along the
line that got them to a position where
they are now at a size where they can
get away we're doing it that
infrequently most of them not all but
most of them used to upload more
regularly philosophy tubes a great
example he started out doing weekly then
it was by Lou bi-weekly and now it's
monthly now in accordance his his
productions have gotten more and more
elaborate but you know he he had to
adjust his schedule as his approach
changed and that is a big thing it's
okay to change your schedule you need to
still keep one I think a video a week
really if you're serious about trying to
build something should be a minimum but
I've changed my schedule about a chunk
of last year I was doing a video a day
and I kept that and I'm actually super
proud that I kept that but I eventually
also laid a point where I'm like I'm not
gonna be able to keep this up so I need
to adjust it now on my own terms before
I bought them out on this and so now I'm
four videos a week now obviously I still
have other things that I think of beyond
these four which is why I start doing
the break room and and things like that
but the break room is not something that
I'm trying to build with the same focus
as this it's just a place for me to do
the sorts of things that used to just be
that I used to do this to fill days but
now I kind of can do for fun so you
don't having back up in ways to vent
things like that that can work but don't
don't over schedule yourself but still
keep a regular schedule next up this is
one that I don't think a lot of people
ever talk about when we talk about
youtubers burning out they
enthusiasm and faked energy a lot of
youtubers both successful and trying to
be successful do really high energy like
artificially high and I'm not knocking
that as a presentation method that's
fine but you do have to be careful
because what your presentation is all
about being like this big hey everybody
how we doing today
okay yeah and you're gonna have that
level you are gonna burn yourself out
just energy
oh just over the course that shoot it is
going to drain you a lot more that sort
of bring it back down a little bit so
you know again finding your own
presentation style is important and if
high energy is part of your presentation
presentation presentation style my
presentation style is clubbing and not
editing it out hey then that's fine but
be careful about trying to be on too
much because if the degree to what
you're trying to be on is significantly
more than your natural sort of way of
being it's going to be more effort which
means it's gonna be more draining which
means it can be a contributor to you
burning out on all of this what I have
next oh this is just sort of a
disheartening thing to watch out for and
that is channel growth stagnation or
plateauing so I've had that happen to me
a few times example for me 2018 was a
really big year for me I went from ten
thousand subscribers to thirty that was
a huge huge year for me and I thought
well I can keep this growth up I wasn't
so naive of us to think that the
increased pace of growth was gonna keep
going but I thought I could do that
again so I thought enter 2019 I'll be at
50 I wasn't I was a little over 40 and
that's and things didn't drop off
steadily but like I went from a period
of fairly steady growth to subscriber
growth going more down here and sort of
staying here and spiking a little and
then staying and
that was disturbing for a while because
I felt like well I must be doing
something wrong I had all this growth
before where did it go well the
algorithm doesn't always favor you and
sometimes you just aren't in the heat in
the moment I got lucky in 2018 I had a
couple of videos like go what was big
for me I had you know some of my earlier
videos on lgbtq+ representation did very
well for me that year um new Doctor Who
at the tail end of the year was a big
boost to get me over the hump at the at
the very end and then we got into 2019
and you know what Doctor Who's not
airing and I'm still talking about it
that takes me out of favor in the
algorithm now I don't regret making the
decision to continue to talk about
Doctor Who even when it was on it wasn't
on the air because a lot of the people
subscribed to me you want that from me
so you also be like this isn't
specifically about burning out but be
careful about chasing growth at the
expense of the people who you already
have you do have to be careful about
that so there's also an inability to
expand this is similar to the niche
topic thing but it's slightly different
because you know your niche topic if
you've gone that road you can maybe
still find things slightly you know
related to it but like start to branch
out and expand a little bit but if you
start to really establish yourself
especially in a format regardless of
topic but if you really build something
around a specific format a presentation
format a video and you try and do
something else even more so than
altering your topic you might lose your
audience doing that because if you have
a presentation style and a format that
people have really gravitated to and
they really enjoy
they will probably stick with you
through topic shifts assuming that you
know it's not completely drastic you
know if you go from talking video games
to start making crafting videos even if
you somehow manage to do that in the
same format you might lose some people
there but you have a little more time a
little more leeway in topic than you do
in presentation a lot of folks you know
you can look at an evolution of
presentations where you know video I
think someone like passion of the nerd
is a good example of that his his videos
have evolved they've gotten more in
depth they've gotten longer but his
format still has been consistent all the
way through to where he is right now and
altering your format ditching the style
and the presentation that people are
currently watching you for that you
really can bite you in the butt but the
flip side of that is if you feel like
you can't change your presentation and
you can't change your format and you
don't have the freedom to experiment
because of the risk of losing who you
have that can also be disheartening and
that can lead to burnout because you can
start to feel trapped by the format
you've made for yourself that you know
you can't alter without losing more than
you can afford to lose so that's another
one next up
um I've got bad news for folks who are
extroverts this is really solitary work
the thing is people always get surprised
when if they find out that youtubers
especially you know the presenters the
people whose faces on these if they are
introverted I'm kind of a weird thing
myself I think of myself as a as a bit
of an introvert and extrovert which I
know sounds completely contradictory but
what I mean by that is if I'm in a
situation where I am comfortable I can
be incredibly extroverted but I do have
to have that initial comfort level you
can't drop me in a party or gathering
full of people who I don't know for an
occasion that
I know nothing about where I feel like
maybe I don't really have a place there
I'm not someone who just go WOW make a
voice for myself no that's not me I'll
be uncomfortable I'll stand in the
corner for wild nettle go home so you
know as much as this presentation like
oh would you put yourself out there you
must be an extrovert no not not as much
as you think I have an ego thing
there's such a thing as introverts with
an ego but the thing is I think some
people get attracted to this by that
sort of presentation of being really
outgoing and like well I'm really
outgoing like yeah but you're gonna do a
lot of this by yourself you're gonna sit
in front of a camera by yourself then
you're gonna sit in front of a computer
and edit by yourself then you're gonna
moderate your comments section by
yourself this I this is very solitary
work and even if you get help like I and
I do have help on my live streams I have
some people who are mods and they are an
immense help I have someone else who
does my thumbnails but you know what
none of them are physically in the same
space as me I communicate with them but
it's it's over the internet and
ultimately I'm still in a room by myself
working at this and if you're not up to
being solitary and working for long
stretches of solitary time like that
you'll find out real quick that this
isn't for you and finally this one
uh-huh sometimes the topic that you're
on and that you want to talk about it
that you've built things around can turn
sour on you that can happen in a number
of ways that can happen in the sense
that something like especially within
geeks fears if something you're a fan of
if the franchise starts going in a
direction or takes a turn that you don't
enjoy that can sour things for you
my friend Ryan who's actually in the
logo I haven't had him on the channel in
a while I gotta get these people back in
here I really do but since scheduling is
a pain in my butt but he had a Star Wars
podcast and he basically stopped doing
it after the last Jedi came out now he
was a bit like me having similar issues
with the last Jedi that weren't the
issues that the loudest most pissy fans
were screaming about but it really sort
of soured his interest in the franchise
and he couldn't bring himself to keep
talking about it so he kind of kind of
stopped now granted that's a podcast
this is a YouTube channel that I'm
talking about but it's kind of the same
principle so that's one way it's also
possible that you can start to examine
something to death if something that you
enjoyed as a hobby and it's something
that you would just did for fun you
start doing that for work effectively
cuz whether this is your living or not
if you're gonna take it seriously you
are effectively taking on it the minimum
a part-time job worth of work you start
doing it for work and it can take some
of the fun out of it and you can find
yourself sitting down to watch something
that used to be nothing but
entertainment and start to analyze it
with an AI that makes you way more
critical of it than you used to be you
find yourself not enjoying it as much
anymore that could be a reason that you
feel that you need to back off and so
that you can stop looking at it through
this through this critical lens or it's
also possible the Hat the fandom that
you have built around itself has gone
nasty I think we've seen that in a
number of areas I don't know of any
instances where I've seen that caused
people to burn out completely on YouTube
but I have seen some folks back off and
take time off from talking about topics
that they used to love because of how
toxic the conversation became and not
even that like they them
those fell toxically about it but like
what was going on in their comment
section and all and what they were and
what they had to see being part of that
community was turning them sour again
I've seen youtubers who have gone
through this in the last few years and
that's another reason that you might
feel like this topic that I came in here
to talk about I don't want to anymore
and like I said I don't think any one of
these is the reason someone will burn
out but these are all things that can
contribute to people kind of throwing up
your hands going I can't do this anymore
so there are things to be aware of
things to be cautious about things that
I have been pretty careful about
wrangling and keeping on top of and yeah
we'll just leave it there ways to burn
out on YouTube there's probably more I
didn't even think of but what are your
thoughts on this or do you have
questions I don't know I don't know if
this is actually helpful to aspiring
youtubers whatever whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it a bunch of
stuff to do you can hop on to my patreon
help me out there be a nice birthday
present cuz it is my birthday this month
but if you also want to physically get
me something I have an Amazon wishlist
and a P o box all down in the
description plus you know like subscribe
all that stuff go on do it or don't end
of the day folks you're the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]